I've stream you know what that means do
we have sound do we have sound can you
hear us
I'm here in New York is pretty crazy
right now I have relatives out there
it's not doing good but what's more
important than the troubles in New York
is can you hear us on this livestream
because that's the most important part
we're calling ICU and we'll get to
talking okay hey we're getting some
suggestions already what is today
overrated movies day are we going from
guilty pleasure to not read the post
today is that we are doing instead of
guilty pleasures you guys can hear us
right yes okay perfect thank you guys we
love you too today instead of doing last
week the theme that we had going
throughout this chat was guilty
pleasures served with movies and then I
started going through like films that
and then shows and then just do anything
you're guilty page you'll see crimes you
committed and then today we're gonna do
the flip side which is movies that
movies that people generally love hmm
that you don't like yourselves no some
super unpopular opinions it's Octavia
candy but right now let's uh let's go
through the chat and see who's in here
and of course yeah then we'll hop right
into things but right now we just want
to kick it kick it with y'all kick it
what's up Tyler Hague
Tyler Haig's and here's cedric canada
representing Jordan Mets I'm sorry about
New York Robert Burke era
all right straight okay well I already
got our Fertile yeah a lot of people in
this chat right now I'm glad to have you
guys here who you got a what's up
specifically I talk about the Disney and
you release schedule
Gabriel Lopez love you too buddy all
right so start submitting guys the films
that you personally don't like that
other people really do like what's your
unpopular opinions and then we'll be
talking
from there hey we got a lot of same
people from last week - that makes sense
based off the time that we're here in
the fact that most people have to stay
at home thank you guys for hanging out
with us today you'll receive a
membership card chance I can't find it
but someone said inside out you know
what I kind of gotta meet you there kind
of I don't love that movie as much as
everyone else does I can appreciate the
craft of it but I'm also in the camp of
when I watch it I was like there's
alright Christ I still cried but I'm
also like very apathetic cry it was like
I'm touched by the end I kind of cried a
lot of things but at the same time I was
also like everyone else and I've never
bothered to revisited since that's your
right and I will fight to the death for
you to have it okay oh hey fusion
perfection thank you so much thank you
so much for your perfection it's really
kind of you e fusion perfection hates
the movie E a pair oh dude e mass movie
movie also bad letter there's a reason
we in America don't give them out in
school Thank You fusion perfection that
is totally okay so but fusion tell us a
movie that you don't like that everyone
else does okay clb is tell me citizen
King King speech my best friend's
wedding Citizen Kane
I've never been able to finish guilty of
that The King's Speech
good performance I see I feel like King
speeches that Oscar Beatty movie that
you know the Academy would absolutely
love but then I walk out me personally
walks out goes it today's the live
stream where I dig myself in a corner
all court shows the topic
oh boy ever to say some things that are
gonna bite me in the ass today aren't
they look out you're gonna lose all your
movie cred and the King speech was that
was like God I mean it was getting all
this praise and I'm like it's like the
best movie of the year weirdly I like
the King's Speech a good amount but even
I too
like thinking back especially really
that's that's what one I love the
photography I'm surprised by my best
friend's wedding LPC not and then here's
rama dick where i suggest this topic and
then i'm gonna go out there and go what
the hell is wrong with you yes I'm gonna
go hey man
even though it's the point of the
question my best friend's wedding I I do
like my best friend's wedding I thought
that buddy was really funny I'm fit and
I like that I like the ending of it that
she does not get the guy in the end yeah
you go spoilers cuz you're a woman
doesn't mean you're gonna win despite
the fact of what the world wants you to
believe now yeah woman are always
winning yeah and despite the fact that
you're you know like a big newspaper
mogul doesn't mean you're necessarily
gonna win true that which true I citizen
came in I think at the right time
because I'm like that's a good movie
well I don't love it I don't hate we're
getting a lot of greats keep them coming
guys cuz we're gonna be going through
this chat and they were talking whoever
makes us maddest wins a prize
oh we got one frozen alright yeah you
know what though I watch frozen the
first time I was like that was cute the
second time I watched it the rewatch I
might and I'll probably next week's
question what movie did you like upon
rewatch and then huh frozen was a film
that I was like you know what the second
time watching it I suddenly got what the
big deal was okay and I only watched it
because we were gonna go watch frozen -
I am still impressed that you made it
that far
what do you mean with not seeing the
first frozen for so long no I saw the
first frozen oh yeah yeah oh I didn't
watch whatever birdie alvorada super
Jets you've got it - why are you still
in the red Sun taking too much money
from billionaires on the island I didn't
like Moana Moana is a beaut okay I can't
say it you're wrong I can't say that
because that's my girlfriend introduced
me to that film and she would flat-out
slice off both of my testicles if I said
I didn't like
on a plain and simple nice okay so I
won't rat you out
but hey honey you're not write anything
cuz I never said I did I'm sorry sorry
sorry I didn't mean to insinuate I'm
gonna say it even if I didn't like Moana
and Gone with the Wind and Breakfast at
Tiffany's I would never say that
publicly those I will take to my grave
take that to my uh I will I will go out
there and say I love those movies no
matter what in fact watch them all
tonight I'm sorry you didn't like Moana
Bernie Sanders yeah but you know what
you still fight for a quality Bernie and
thank you for contributing to the
superjet today yeah none of that super
chat money came from a super PAC oh I'm
seeing some end game in here I mean in
game is yeah I almost hadn't thought I'm
not gonna say Star Wars the last Jedi
counts I can't I can't not give it to
the folks in the chat who are saying
Star Wars the last Jedi it just doesn't
work today
yes all right so what do we have at our
I feel like the world probably agrees
now they have a times over
people started agreeing the second at
left I feel like Dark Knight Rises
already like a debatable movie you know
what I mean I feel like when people
don't like the Dark Knight in case I'm
seeing the eyes on the chat the in case
you guys don't know what we're doing
right now we're doing movies that people
that you don't like that people
generally love Liam Lynch whatever I
hope you're doing okay in Scotland all
right so uh all right what else do we go
there's a lot of avatar here see I think
the fact that a lot of people are saying
avatar goes to support the point that
you were just saying all Pirates of the
Caribbean movies well if you said the
first one I'd give it to you but the the
ones following the first one Saving
Private Ryan
Duke ourselves Nazi in here oh yeah you
hate America that's I mean that's I feel
like war movie especially as a touchy
subject for this conversation so good on
you for being bold
fusion perfection here thank you so much
this
saying interstellar uh John FETs I will
meet you honestly I think there's a
whole heap ton to appreciate about
interstellar but as far as Chris Nolan's
films go I it is one that I don't love
through and through so I will give it to
you
I can I can fathom why anybody wouldn't
care for the complete film there's so
much great stuff in it though so I'll
come halfway oh well okay I gotta give
you an honest opinion about interstellar
I got into a fight with someone before
watching that movie okay oh wait I think
I've heard that yeah I got into a fight
so I couldn't I had the hardest time
paying attention because I was so hung
up on my argument that I was gonna play
out oh I'm gonna talk to this person
afterwards Oh monologue really do a lot
of reflection on the film post it
remembering the images and stuff so it's
in order to give a proper review of the
film but I really should revisit it
after after such time as I believe in
another so thing that happens with a lot
of people Fusion perfectionist still be
talking to you because you brought the
interstella more is that a lot of times
people get into [ __ ] before they have to
review movies and then they have to like
I mean before they watch a movie that
they have to review I've heard a bunch
of times like personal things come up
and then they go I mean uh I needed like
readjust my mindset and remember what
happened in that film and how did I feel
about interstellar I will say get like
was the closest I felt to like this must
have been what it was like seeing 2001
like at least for the technical side of
it so yeah I remember I remember like
certain images got some hot eggs near
DCE you better than MCU oh I would say
the way a big DC versus Marvel has been
a ongoing battle for a very long time my
friend so lost flat out said I hate
Tobey Maguire you know take a toke
Maguire we
expanded the the guilty pleasures last
time we'll expand this one to Nyssa John
you must serenade her because she is in
love with you and she wants to cuddle
with you every night every time she
messaged me on patreon but she says
thank you so much in this side thank you
and Nisa I can hear y'all I love y'all
thank you for getting me through all of
this personally every day I wasn't a big
fan of Pulp Fiction waited so long to
watch it to wait for the right time and
I was let down I'm so sorry to hear that
yeah the first time I watched both
fiction I was in love with it either but
I was also like 9 years old when I watch
both hey that's a great question what
movie were you not young and old enough
to appreciate let's yeah let's let's
let's branch it out all right what movie
was too hyped for you guys what movie
did you do not like that people
generally loved it what movie would just
flat out way to overhype for you before
you watch it probably let you down or
that you watched it the wrong time in
life like if you see Goonies in your
mid-20s right
well okay perfect is honestly when I saw
Paul fiction the first time I was just
greatly I was a kid I wasn't even a
teenager yet yeah so I was very much
disturbed by the Bruce Willis storyline
after these calipari when you first let
me borrow that movie you prepped me for
that specific yeah I was very disturbing
um but yeah overhype can really do that
especially a film like pulp fiction it
took me a while to appreciate it I
remember my complaint there's so much
talking
he probably supplanted some of those
subconscious writing mechanisms in your
mind that way yeah that's true
now everything I write is just so much
so much dialogue too much dialogue and
now we have fallen behind on the chat
here No
but thank you so much in this I hope
you're being safe say hi to your family
for me you're always taking care of them
hi Jenna someone says the whole Star
Wars saga not one of them damn that's
that's a comprehensive hot day that must
be very challenging for you to be in
movie circles I'd imagine you know three
out of nine in that equation is at least
a hot take it's not a complete hot take
but it's at least a good third of a hot
take oh my whoa holy crap
this rarely happens okay so people like
appreciate the super chats obviously
like we always any youtuber does anyone
who does these live streams absolutely
does thank you so much
any amount is like yeah that's [ __ ]
awesome rarely is it like super sad and
someone just gave Ted I six one six I'm
having a hard time finding your collar
but you popped up you're rolling
goodness gracious
thank you so much I'm I'm actually taken
I'm sorry this is this is this would
have been a good time for
guilty-pleasure topic because this this
right here for some reason has always
led to feeling a little guilt accepting
love from you guys it says Haga he says
hey guy dead eyes six one six hey guys I
love your content hope you're staying
safe and as far as the movie I don't
like I'd have to say Blood Diamond Leo
DiCaprio with the South African accent
can't do it Oh guys I love your content
I'm working on it I'm working on it ever
since district 9 I'm les South African
so hard to do it thank you so much for
your your major contribution there Dead
Eye six one six that's a very seriously
everybody in the chat just give some
love now what I go on a spending spree
thank you so much they're gonna buy so
much friggin time we're gonna hold up
the stores now that's what you've done
you created a problem now for everyone's
quarantine situation we're gonna hog
like a [ __ ] I'm gonna just drop
a dollar in the middle of six people and
watch the chaos reign he said I'd have
to say Blood Diamond I thought it was a
fantastic movie do you guys like Blood
Diamond I thought it was great
do you like Blood Diamond I think Djimon
Honsou is one of the most underrated
actors working today for some reason he
gets into giant ass films like guardians
of the galaxy like Shazam like cast in
marble and it gets he's like tiny ass
roles when really he's an amazing ass
Hollywood needs more respect for gem on
hunts here's what else I would say
though about DiCaprio to your point at I
6 1 6 when it comes to Blood Diamond I
would say if I were to watch it now I
might be more distracted than before
because of who DiCaprio I liked that was
he that came out right at the same time
with the departed and the departed was
right when I started to lovely to her -
yeah he was brave man barrier I was
always in the the camp of I really liked
a Caprio but I don't ever fully believe
him and the departed was the first time
other than films like Gilbert Grape
where I was truly really was like he's
becoming a man and I really believed
this guy whereas films like aviator
engage New York it's still feeling like
trying cash you've cancer you should
rape but departed man that I loved his
performance and then right after that I
saw blood of time and I'm like so that
might have had an effect but I wonder
now if I watch it today I would suddenly
be like good I don't really buy this
south south african accent yeah they
should have cast ninja from dee Antwoord
oh what wreck the third okay Shrek the
Third Reich the third is that was when
Shrek started going I got started going
up Forest Gump
that's exactly why I haven't seen for
Scott as it's over this point there's no
way for us go can live up to the hype
and the amount of people who have said
to me you haven't see Forrest Gump yeah
I know what you can do though watch all
the Robert Zemeckis movies in reverse
order until you get to Forrest Gump and
that will will steadily get better as a
movie marathon that's sure that's a good
point watch some of his not
well-received recent effort Forrest Gump
has been such a weird thing for me
because as a matter of fact a week
I had an opportunity I had is my my turn
to choose a movie and I was about to put
on Forrest Gump and then two things hit
me one this movie has I've gone in so
much of you haven't seen Forrest Gump
yet then I was like that's probably
gonna just be a letdown and ii was i
kind of have this weird thing where i
it's part of my identity now that I
haven't seen for us Forrest Gump is what
blade is for me what really I've never
seen blade I went I haven't seen boy I
begged my [ __ ] is wrong with you yeah
freaking freak I was like go to insult
you parboured miscreants no yeah I
begged my parents I thought the poster
in the in the calendar section looks so
cool so I begged them to take me and we
went and I remember the opening club
scene happened and you know some there
was a hand on my face and then some guy
took a like a knife through the lower
jaw and then we were in the car heading
home and since then I've never seen the
film blade and it's the same kind of
thing where I'm like now I can't now I
have to keep this up forever because
it's never not that the stakes are as
high for blade as for Forrest Gump but
you know now it's got this whole you
know identity in my mind but there's
been three then and another one to come
and I've seen no Madea movies that's
gonna be my secret Schmoe down category
I'm just getting a really good at Tyler
Perry
what Raisa Skywalker's very debatable
people in here Oh Carter loved Joe
Carter thank you so much Carter Lovejoy
level every Saturday Carter Lovejoy it's
in this live stream unless some of you
guys I see frequently and Carl of drove
a guy right here thank you so much dude
fast and furious which one are you
talking about
there's a gajillion in that bar that is
that the only one you don't like they're
all underrated acceptable you could just
be talking about fast and furious heart
are you talking about all the fast or
ally to battle angel Korean really
didn't come over yeah I feel like you
got me they gotta be movies though that
like critics and audiences both really
adore
yeah they've got to be generally
respected or review having most MCU
films and Joker oh my god you just
brought your bucket of hot tape whoa
dude
most Nolan films don't hate him in his
films he and his film gets you a bribe I
am the biggest [ __ ] I know I'm the
one who posed this question I'm just
like I want to know which Nolan films
you do like in which MCU films do like
because you said most you said most
which lives up to the hype and doesn't
like Joker Wow you must you must really
love Martin Scorsese films then huh I
think all of Nolan's films lived up to
the hype I just hate him as a person
yeah pretty sure he's a sexist racist
[ __ ] I remember we were there when I
met Nolan for like a second because yeah
I did the same thing she was there with
like a bunch of real bunch of kids yeah
at the IMAX yeah and then his child was
texting him being like why didn't you
invite me
dad why do you spend time with the world
and not us he's like that therapist who
didn't know who's like great with his
clients would not good with his own wife
well hey got a respected man that was
the question yeah yeah a lot of really
good answers a matter of fact these
we're getting getting more answers here
than the guilty-pleasure ones what a
sweet what I'm learning is that hot
takes are great for engagement come with
the quit a gone with the wind great
movie
I hate I hate how about it let's listen
we'll expand the question a little bit
what's the movie you can clearly see is
like oh I can see why people think this
is a great movie but hmm I really don't
like it for me there would have to be
Casablanca I just cannot get on board
okay
seen it like three times and I said I
have up for see your life three times
but I just cannot get on board with that
movie for some reason yeah but I I'm
it's not like I don't like old films I
just for some reason every time I watch
God mom like I'm bored I'm really bored
I'll probably take a fair amount of [ __ ]
for this one but um yeah one on one
film that I don't care to argue against
I don't think is I think it's very well
made very worth appreciating film but
there will be blood I just had a very
objective really there will be blood
yeah I love that I I would like to watch
it again to be fair cuz it's been a long
time but yeah when I saw that movie I
felt like I missed something I was like
yeah yeah everything people are praising
is here I experienced the movie I
thought there will be blood would be
that for me and I I do love that movie
and I still if anyone ever meets my
girlfriend you'll see you ask her
i weirdly that that's the one movie I
still quote like every week I just walk
around going to the best all-time
classic go look at the S&L milk she's
like what do you mean person to me yeah
and like I love the memes that have come
out of the movie and like yeah when I
think about it in micro moments and
performances and like all its elements
separately I'm like yeah this is hate
Moulin Rouge
so hey Jenna Randolph is in here how you
doing
Lord of the Rings writing says all Harry
Potter movies wow that's I'm sorry to
hear that I'm sorry to hear that captain
you hate Captain Marvel trust me us
giving a positive review for Captain
Marvel Gabriel hot take that was the hot
man lanai lanai here avatar is terrible
that's my Texas actually is from Texas
she's a doll thank you so much Lynnae
Jones John ever touched her avatars
terrible watching WrestleMania with no
audience wait they're doing WrestleMania
maybe they're in a kiddie pool full
gonna fight each other maybe maybe it's
like mud wrestling but it's all hand
sanitizer
no they all the time that would be the
most surreal it's a necessity all right
grocery stores are open and so is
wrestling listening to y'all Plus Seth
Rollins oh wait he's on right now you're
listening simultaneously wow that must
be fun how we sound tracking Seth
Rollins avatar avatar has been the most
popular thank you so much lanai avatar
has been uh the the number one thing I'm
reading in this chat that everyone keeps
listening as a movie they don't like
that everyone loves I think avatar was
was the weirdest hypetrain movie because
it was almost instantaneous I thought it
wasn't like time had passed and then it
became this movie that everyone was
crapping on no week - it was like who's
like what the [ __ ] is everyone getting
hyped yeah incredible than the other
half were like oh this is terrible it's
Fern Gully
and honestly I was there a punch I've
never rewatched it the first time I
watched it I was there halfway through
going I don't know why everyone has this
movie I saw I everyone's like you gotta
watch it imax 3d to it and that's my jam
right there I'm an IMAX nut and honestly
like I I watched it in IMAX 3d and I was
halfway through it god I don't get what
and I hadn't seen a single this before
trailer react and we were doing trailer
reactions I hadn't seen a single trailer
for the movie I would walk out of the
theater if I saw that they were gonna
start avatar trailer and I would come
back in and ice and I'm so literally
goin in cold there was nothing for me to
anticipate other than I heard this is a
great film and I still couldn't I did
not I loved it just gonna get into it so
yeah Lynnae I got to agree with you dear
oh my goodness I don't want to get ahead
of ourselves but oh my goodness story
I'm noticing : I love you - Colby
Franklin thank you so much my friend
that is a sexy profile pic right there
look at that swoosh I Jenna we did
notice you okay we got Meghan Isaac hi
hi hi Meghan that's my sister's name by
the way cats is a creepy move in Peter
Rabbit haven't seen
yet okay that's can't be overrated raka
Dillo John do your best wreck Rocket
Raccoon impression and Captain Marvel
Bree Lawson wasn't good to me it's
better than what I would have done you
know I was I started to do and I was
like this will be fine it won't be good
but it'll be fine
yeah I would agree with you on that but
I say Harold Denver's not real ours I
don't go see your same or the writing
this character handling yes okay that's
fair I don't know there's a couple of
scenes where I think her performance
really Falls like insanely flat I'm sure
I constantly flash to when her ship
crashes and then she picks up was a
[ __ ] like a net betting and she's
just like so like nothing nothing but I
like the movie I do I think it's a I I
think it's a lot of fun but I respect
your paint and I [ __ ] love your your
icon there damn the road Rocket Raccoon
looks like you sipping an ice cream or
like a popcorn I love that cosmic right
there MCU cosmic perfect perfect okay
some people are some people are saying
Toy Story 4 I'm sorry to hear that
one person said Toy Story 4 is better
than 3 do so at least there's a little
love okay we got a Steve character here
saying I hated zodiac the first time but
years later watching and loved it I
think zodiac is David that's my personal
favorite David Fincher movie who's
Carter Lovejoy sarcasm alert thank you
Batman V Superman hey hey hey hey Martha
am i right at least cut okay alright
we're going down the chat here the
sandlot oh good oh wow I grew up with
that one that's one that yeah especially
we didn't see that at the right time I
can see you not caring that much whoa
holy crap okay we got Britney lane here
tweeting us with a bird hey you all
thanks for the sticker Thank You Britney
how's uh how's Canada doing is that
thing going all right thank you so much
a sticker that's what it is yeah hey do
you think we should get memberships guys
everyone's telling us we should get
memberships and by everyone I mean three
people we can't people are pressuring us
into getting memberships you should do
that you yourself could have special
abilities and special stickers for the
low low price of a couple bucks I'm
gonna kneel down here really fast I'm
squatting 19:17 Marina says oh man if
you want to go I thought I thought that
was great I adore that movie all right
okay flatline holy [ __ ]
thank you guys thank you so much that's
so kind of you especially a little
skeptical yeah and especially right now
during the where money is especially
precious like thank you little
overwhelmed yeah it says violent eases
love the content guys I always feel like
I have something great to look forward
to when I get notifications keep it up
and stay safe out there well thank you
God thank you flatline eighty-seven I
hope you never flatline and I hope
you're super chatham flatline to think
of that and hot take the remake of
Flatliners is great yeah [ __ ] great
takers you
Anisa liver Anissa Anissa you could hit
the brakes a little bit you you're
you're gonna get like four extra shots I
feel like y'all deserve it so much it
brings so much happiness to our lives
and so supportive truly such a beautiful
and amazing Souls you don't know us in
person you don't you don't know us in
person now not only with the office I
say a lot of evil thing both you and
Flatliners should know I say a lot of
nasty things about people behind their
back mm-hmm and I'll never say it to
their face in fact I say quite the
opposite it's really weird with Daniel
is living like right next door to
because he's always doing with the
windows open yeah and they have they
they arrive me many times they have some
evidence on me or just let me under the
door
guilty movie pleasure brats ha I've
never seen the brats movies you're not
gonna lie yeah I'll give it to you I'll
give you the guilty pleasure of brats
avatar with
a flatlined earnest - thank you God
thank you both so much that's super
sweet of you guys and I you know like
whenever well whoever super Chaz I was
like how do we make them feel special
and I I don't really know what to do
other than John show them your nipple
thank you talk about my nipples a long
time I've been naked on this channel
it's only right that John shows a nipple
once in a while yeah I joined in the
naked sketch back in the day
it's precedented elby's never seen
avatar neither has kathryn bigelow I'll
have you know weirdly I would say you
don't have to except for the cultural
significance Mimi says hereditary mood
some are both made well did not like it
I also Mimi I often find that with like
art house or actually is some time off
tinfoil into that camp it's like yeah no
I get it
people love it I just don't yeah yeah
but I really do like her actually my
rewatch of hereditary I I like the first
time much hereditary I was kind of
detached but the second time I watched
it I fell in love with the film still
haven't seen midsummer oh let's check it
out
watch it twice this whole talk has
become about avatar everyone is talking
about avatar vide we got a new one here
Thank You Brittany the number one movie
I don't like is the child's play saga
hate that doll I can't blame you can't
blame me for that did you I actually
like that we like that I think an
unpopular opinion we like the child's
play remake approve both John and I like
that movie and I actually wrote just
recently McCann a ripoff of child ripoff
it's called hockey I wrote a script that
it's it's only like 50 pages but it's
it's a moose I won't go into specifics
but uh I don't know why I'm bringing it
over I can't go over specific wrote my
own version of Haunted doll with a child
but it takes a really weird different
turn
as I know the structure of those stories
all the time boy girl gets doll parents
like [ __ ] weird all crazy
that's let the doll that's you you're
being [ __ ] stupid kid and that's how
the parents talk in the movie they're
all like shitty kid the reason we didn't
get you a buzz like I know instead of
buzz they gave him Chuckie arguers
because they're both in band well you
gotta explain the joke John for gonna do
that's how funniness happens when you
explain it so there was but ya know I
I'm generally not a fan of that
structure so I can beat you on that but
child's play like really evolved into
something else no have you seen all them
though Britney because most are not good
but there are some in there that are
pretty freakin solid yeah it is why I
feel like every slasher franchise has
that quality where it's like there are
hopefully a couple they're pretty good
and then the rest are just you know
crazy schlocky slashers oh okay we got
scuba siva Steve thank you so much a
kitchen I could probably get a lot of
trouble for this and I've mentioned this
on the channel Anna Scuba Steve shut up
I'm gonna tell you guys right now like
probably a lot of trouble for this now
I'm like really do the Steve's illegal
not really worried you know everyone
[ __ ] does it everyone lies to try to
get out of jury duty I don't know what's
the person who doesn't lie when they're
being interviewed for jury duty okay so
some people are I notice through before
seem like they're the most truthful are
the ones who never get picked and I cuz
they're calm in that moment I use scuba
Steve when I was asked about do I know
anyone who does certain activities and I
was like I have a friend named Steve in
the East Coast who does graffiti work
that's an actual thing I said to try to
get my passage as if knowing some guy in
Rhode Island who would be like this
guy's this Greg elbows linked to
criminal activity no way
as you know there was a montage
happening where we zoom into the
internet tubes and then we wind up back
on the East Coast where the FBI swarms
on Steve we are kneeling right now
because we are praising everyone who is
here in this chat with these uh these
thank you for all the great conduct you
helped me forget the hell on earth where
and now love you guys stay safe I didn't
care for Matt scuba you have addressed
the one movie
I dare not mention that I did not love
Mad Max fury road that is a film I can
say I on a technical scale I really
appreciated the action and everything
but and and you know it took me on
I took me awhile into doing reviews to
be as honest as I like to be and I think
around the time fury road came out I
didn't really talk much about what I
didn't care for with it and I don't
really remember the movie now but I
remembered going now that was one of the
movies that came out and it had that
feeling for me of what's wrong with me
you love that I do but I know that
feeling that feeling of very well
everyone loves it if I go out there and
say I don't love it does that say
something about me as a human being am I
gonna die alone like I like it
I enjoy it but I kind of feel this way
about the Mad Max franchise in general
that I think about it that adds
legitimacy to your hot take there that's
true thank you Joe thank you John for
adding legitimacy well I'll take hold
you up I'm just here to bolster IMAX is
over Carter Lovejoy you just seen [ __ ]
right now just try to get me mad get
booted from the room oh man shark as
long as it's sharknado 3 oh hell no is
better than a bug's life
that's an odd comparison Jack and Jill
but you know okay I got a guilty
pleasure for you now that Carter
Lovejoy's bringing this up Jack and Jill
I actually kind of enjoyed that film I
can see an Al Pacino doing a weird rap
song line selling out like a
[ __ ] in there like enjoy
well yeah I mean cuz it's an oddity of
the timeline we live on you know hey
some people like cheese in here that's
cool avatar is basically Disney's a lot
of things Oh Jared pen thank you so much
my friend thank you that's really kind
of like that really means a lot thank
you you know what I'm a matter of fact
I'm not even gonna read your city or
your comment I'm just gonna go thank you
that means a lot John add on to that it
means a lot a lot a lot my son so much
you would like too much it means too
much actually I'm concerned thank you I
don't know if I can process this along
with everything else that means
something to me moving on I love the
structure of some of these just due to
the nature of the conversation that
we're all having because a lot of these
start out is like hey big fan of you
guys also I I hate this movie for those
who are coming in and out of the chat or
people who are just joining we're doing
movies that people don't like and what's
funny is we haven't had to change the
topic seems like yeah no really we have
to like change the topic up a little bit
it seems like everyone's able to
contribute to this pretty well hey by
genuinely geeky guys thank you for being
here no you have to go see it Kiki so
yeah okay hey guys big fan been watching
your channel for years hope yours oh
yeah the topic is movies that people
love that you don't really like hope
you're safe my pick is the Irishman
loved Scorsese but this was way too long
and boring task or noms no wins I think
having it on Netflix ruined it wait I'm
a little bit confused by what you're
saying though are you saying are you
saying that because it's on Netflix
that's what ruined the movie that is
that you might have enjoyed it if it was
in the theaters if it was a bigger
theatrical experience for you one more
immersive or are you suggesting that
because it's on Netflix it was way too
long so if it was that out in the
theaters they might have trimmed the
movie down so that way they could have
better play in the theaters is that what
you're trying to say um and to that note
I disagree I love the Irish it was one
of my favorite movies of 2019 I thought
brilliant but I did see it in the
theaters and they were very very strict
on no cell phone usage so I was I was
definitely able to get immersed in the
experience I've got a bit of an
advantage there and then I bought a new
phone later that night Oh
jokes tonight where John explains his
appreciating that's what I want is to do
a stand-up routine where no one laughs
at the time but every joke is away when
they're driving home Chuck I think I get
the other joke too and then you just
kind of laugh alright so coming to I
haven't seen come wait no I I saw come
to America no I can't I don't remember
it but apparently it's like the greatest
comedy of all time yeah it won the Oscar
for brights film of all time I'm seeing
some triggered arguments happening in
here for the movie Billy Madison this is
a topic that sure do this why I didn't
put it in the title I don't want to like
people might fight about it in the chat
with certain movies but I'm just put it
in the chat if I put it in the title
people are gonna specifically chime in
just to trigger other people I just love
the Billy Madison is the one that's
starting off actually Madison's the one
was like whoa whoa whoa too much all
right
freakin right-wing Nazis that were you
that's agreeable Adam Sandler movie give
us the nice things while they last
no I'm not saying the whole point in
saying right we cannot see a southern
voice was the idea that that doesn't
make sense to do it in the southern
voice I just need to make that clear
before people think Greg is making a
political statement there wasn't for
Bernie Sanders by the way now it is
turning out great okay so all right we
got wait this person super chatted and
then the chat it's saying message
restricted what the hell did you say
that's getting your message restricted
right here we got to see it thank you
for
super chat by the way buddy nothing all
right so let's see here for some reason
it's saying on our end it that it the
message is restricted but but we got it
hopefully you can see it on screen the
Dark Knight Rises
sucks it was boring it's shallow that's
it we blocked the keyword shat yeah I
was I was sick of people saying the word
shat because it was thing you could do
in YouTube where you could put in a word
you don't want pop it up in your
comments anymore
and I put the word shat in there yeah we
only [ __ ] in the present tense yeah
it's shat all over the lower Batman I
think was trying too hard a little bit
to the realism of its predecessor we did
a whole podcast called haters why we
love The Dark Knight Rises ever did may
we refer you to them I'm gonna I'm gonna
tell you guys where that came from going
off of your I can respect that
B and trust me I've had a lot of people
really tell me to my face why the Dark
Knight Rises sucks and how that reflects
on you is so I'm gonna tell you what
happened I was having a birthday
gathering and I was small group of
people and my old friend David Henry he
might know from Wizards of Waverly Place
was there and then [ __ ] got very awkward
because we got into a very heated
argument about why he hates the tide
rises oh and then before you know it
everyone is just really quiet and very
uncomfortable because we are like pretty
much yelling at each other which made me
go I'm gonna do a podcast it was a big
learning lesson in don't get to heat it
in real life over disagrees yeah it was
a really big that's a true story it was
a very big learning lesson for me I feel
like that is an important barrier that
every you know
and um within people reaches is the
point where you go I guess I don't have
to feel bad if somebody I like doesn't
like the same thing I like you're like
it's not worth it and I can like and all
I remember are the faces of I don't even
remember what we argued about
specifically I remember is looking at
the faces and seeing how uncomfortable
everyone was at the table as that first
it starts off funny like haha they're
having a fun going back and forth debate
and then eventually it just became so
heated that I was like I rewrite to have
a fall out have like a friendship end
over this yeah or that side of life I
know we're taking a long time like per
question and the the truth is there's
been so many like computer technical
issues over the last couple days and
that this is the most fun I've had all
week with YouTube we are having a I know
we're like we might be taking questions
and going on for a long time but this is
like the most relaxing and honestly when
we do live streams it so it's also like
a great reminder as to why we love doing
the channel because reading comments is
one thing but getting to interact
directly and going back and forth makes
a big difference you know being here
with you even though we're not like it
really does you feel it yeah you feel
that connection so thank you so
quarantine Ian can suck but I gotta say
that like being here and the livestreams
has been absolutely the biggest
highlight like we did a collab with
cosmic wonder we're gonna put up a video
tomorrow I got to finish it every web
stream actually taking it such a long
time to put together because discuss the
technical [ __ ] but it's not even that
like it's something like a hyper edited
video but anyway just my point being is
it's like before hopping on the
livestream well we were like maybe sure
we cancel it because we got [ __ ] to do
that afterwards but I really do love
being here so so thank you I don't I'm
not gonna cry let's just keep having
punisher warzone love
um yeah I just want I really did want to
just throw that out there so thank you
to everyone who's here look guys this is
really a blast and not to belabor the
point but I think that one of the nice
things to remember in a situation such
as this one that does have so many
terrible downsides there is a relief
image and I think one of the many little
less negative byproducts is that we're
all gonna I think find ways to use
technology to actually connect now yeah
you know instead of using it to each
other apart yeah that's true so amen to
that yeah very true
all right guys well if you're new to the
chat and you just got in here the main
topic we have going on today just as a
reminder is movies that people love
I mean movies people love that you don't
really care for the Graduate almost as a
graduate no I said the guy that's my big
one that's my big I know I know you love
that movie
and I will that's the movie that's one
of the movies I look at and go never
told me this
I've never told you this oh no this is
life mo hi would you wait to be on
camera to tell me information I know and
I don't think it's bad it's not one of
those where I'm like I don't get it I'm
just like I don't know why this leaves
me so cold
and I and I and I get it's one of those
god I puzzle over that movie I'm
actually I read his life straight taking
home that's strangely emotional genuine
Dern like the last couple live streams
have been [ __ ] around a lot of that
I've been noted and I've been noticing
in this live stream we're probably gonna
get a lot more sincere oh these okay I
feel morally reprehensible right now you
see like I forgot what video we did a
reaction to a video of mr. craps just
talking about what our characters and in
that video and obviously I mean like a
lot of like and and also to the people
who are super - I know we're like
reading off
we are reading off people's comments
that are not like strictly super Jazz's
well people there to beware that but to
the people who are super chatting it
does mean a hell of a lot right now -
with the way YouTube has been like the
this is this has been a major
contribution and a big helper actually
so so thank you I don't want to deny
that or a sugarcoat it so like thinking
this is surprising because how many of
you guys have been doing it it's been
it's because we've done live streams
plenty of times but this is this is
honestly really surprised you know so
thank you guys this is probably the most
so the but to to go back to the graduate
I wanted to say to you on that is when
we were doing the reaction in the mr.
crappiest video one of the things I was
saying is with characters there's a lot
of times I think we're living
vicariously through them and when I was
young I grew up with I like the weirdly
the very first character that I've ever
seen where he this character set a line
that and it was the first time I've ever
like I've said that before but I've
never heard a character say that I'm
sure this wasn't the first character
that's ever said something like this but
it was the first time I heard it and
when I was younger I used to say I feel
empty and that didn't make any sense to
me and the first character I heard say
that was Dexter but of all characters it
was Dexter from the show Dexter the
serial killer and and and and I felt
this weird sense of identical lot of
people identify with that character do
we in a weird way and so my point with
that was like that's just to show you an
example of a character experiencing an
emotion and they're they're putting it
out on display that I can live
vicariously through and connect with and
weirdly there were - - there were three
films that gave me the feeling of what
it must be like to be in love when I was
younger
hmm and I cuz I I didn't fall in love -
like wait that's my teens right so when
I was younger I saw three movies that
made me like go like cry over the
feeling of what it must be like to be in
love and that was Moulin Rouge and
American Graffiti weirdly it's this
moment
howard's running after his girl after
she gets in a car crash with Harrison
Ford and and and the Graduate which is a
[ __ ] bizarre movie to list that for
because of a weird love relationship
dynamic that's a triple feature but
there was something about what he's it
though he's trying to stop the widow the
way that really hit me as a kid and and
I really did fall in love with and a guy
who was kind of I don't know what it was
there's something I really that really
did click with me I was a kid I wasn't a
high school graduate or a college
graduate at the time that was just so
yeah so I take your [ __ ] I know and
now somebody else is saying the matrix
everyone's out to get whatever make the
subject the graduate is one of those
movies that I reserved one of those like
maybe if I watch it you know a third or
fourth time you know I'll click in a
different way with you got watch at
least six times I've got six times what
really starts to get you Scarface to is
as I think when we can agree on the
people love that I've never really cared
much for yeah I was addicted to Scarface
but I've never loved it it was [ __ ]
weird I'm just doing this to self punish
well I think I think like the circle of
friends we had like David Haley was part
of that and then we had a friend Brandon
and we just [ __ ] carry a mob movie we
we were super into mob movies movie kid
like and I think this I do have a lover
because we were really into like David
Sicilian I'm technically half's is like
the tech that I did my DNA test right it
was so you're everywhere so a lot of it
but I believe my family's mainly
Sicilian on the Italian side spectrum
and so we were like heavily into mob
movies a Pacino with didn't hero because
of that fact you're the De Niro come to
find out he's more I understand Italian
[ __ ] [ __ ] why do us all these
years so yeah and face Italian to our
face was the movie yeah that we just
they had this weird resurgence I won't
remember that like weird research it was
I add to everyone's t-shirt during the
late 90s early 2000s like yeah and we
and I so I was
watch it although I remember one time we
have like a mini DVD player we just sat
on the kitchen counter and watch two and
A two A plus hours the world anyway back
to back on track that sometimes we see a
movie and it just springs it Springs I
think that's the thing with movies is
that why I like having this topic where
they has become as introspective thing
because sometimes reading these movies
from you guys makes me realize like the
emotional connections of how I heard
thought back to where the motion creates
memory and I feel like that's what a lot
of this is uh oh yeah a lot of this is
doing for me right now it's Samar seems
to be a common thing here hmm
identity with John Cusack I have seen
them I like them yeah I do love that one
Oh what Anissa Wow you would have to
triple your patreon pledge if that was
the case we would make sure that happens
we have ways what if I said I just say
hated the matrix just okay whoa whoa if
you say you hate the matrix fine but if
you say you don't like him she gave me
an awesome matrix sure by the way I love
that shirt just a like Keanu Reeves as a
whole I think he's a terrible shots
fired that's one of the things that
people would immediately go no one
thinks Keanu Reeves a bad person no one
time where we are where e'er than ever
to elevate celebrities we still really
our last hope thank you for is that your
tinder profile pic it should be it's
very inviting everyone be swiping right
on all night that's what I'd say
everyone we swipe and write all night
swipe right swipe from right all night
okay so that we got here what do we what
else do we got go
all right what other movies you're
seeing here okay a lot of some people
there's a lot of Defense for fury road
right now yeah there you go
fury road is is my graduate
I got a shout out Roberts question why
is there a sequel to The Godfather but
not to mr. Magorium's wonder Emporium
get on it Hollywood Dustin Hoffman's not
busy okay Kate man Steve I got it yeah I
got agree with you there um he's talking
about the original Mad Max being very
bad like that's his opinion might not be
yours road warrior and beyond that heard
over so much better and I gotta agree
like fury road was coming out my mom
grew up a Mel Gibson addict she took all
the photos down from her office after
some [ __ ] happened with the police
officer I'm always obsessed with Mel
Gibson I'm not I'm not for I inherited
it from she's the lot this is not your
fault this is a true thing Gibson I was
conditioned over time
she used to like and I didn't know this
till recently
she would constantly tell people like
cuz she's in her office she's the
manager at a health insurance company
and then she would people she would have
like photos of Mel plastered everywhere
one day as a surprise party all her
co-workers did these like before
Photoshop existed they would like find
ways to do this did this like printouts
were they take moments of Mel Gibson
like the one then Lethal Weapon where
he's tied up they would have air bubbles
and it'd be like no I would never say I
don't love you toys when I say that
Joyce I never never I've never say that
about you Joyce and and she had like Mad
Max memorabilia and there she was
we're like strangely obsessed with Mel
Gibson and she would tell people my
dad's name is Steven and she would save
Stevens not Gregory's father Mel Gibson
this is like subconsciously am i maybe
it's true this isn't gonna be an Arthur
Fleck story for you
no he's gonna punch me in a bathroom and
everyone's gonna believe he did that my
mom used to handle your health insurance
so so yeah one time like Figaro is
coming out Mel Gibson's reputation was
tarnished and I was like you know what
but I got an honor to the mount I need
to finally watch those Mad Max movies
started with the original and I was like
this is a chore I'm gonna finish this
off
thank God those next two are so much
better than the original
I have the hardest time I had the
hardest time sitting through the
original I did not like that movie yeah
that's a movie that I wouldn't take up
arms against somebody with because it is
so low Phi and so Scud that I I can
fully understand the Hawaii it wouldn't
appeal fair enough
just fight qualities that it does have
fair enough who can June 24 look at that
cowboy wow thank you can't you
appreciate that
oh man are you a top or bottom cuz I'll
be your bottom Oh
or maybe you could just switch it I'm
gonna find out he's in Semyon history
I'm message saying gays like hardcore
homophobic why'd you say that why just
say that fine you a kick your ass which
is really public man come here for your
politics man anyway we haven't seen
sunlight or toilet paper for this kind
of going a little insane and in here to
be honest like every day I'm a little
bit more on edge Roger Rabbit next week
so where we at Delhi yes eating the same
calm really found but it gets your
question Ken Chung that's a great name
ken Shawn like an action hero yeah
Street Fighter character sounds like Ken
and chun-li they all get this common ten
minutes too late you see the thing is I
notice that a lot of live streams people
kind of just speed round through
questions or certain things and I'm late
Liam I just don't want to edit right
you're gonna have us here for a while
you can see the chat but but
sit on the opposite end and tell me it's
not hard to get every kind attention
you lookin handsome I hate all JJ Abrams
Kurtzman ork see prescript CV films
except for fringe for fringe episodes
yeah and my movie is those were led by
tankers mainly bad robot ruins Star Trek
and Wars send me to Terminator purgatory
SIA Costco Burbank he lives in
California
oh I did wait a minute you go to Costco
Burbank oh I'll be filling my guest the
one trip I will make to the public
tomorrow is gonna be two that is they
are you leaving a clue that you've seen
John at Costco and didn't say anything
he's there a lot I see a lot of comments
of people who not in the chat people
come and seeing me a cousins like he's a
very unapproachable guy he's karen bulk
items hey I'm gonna keep my eyes peeled
for you I am at the gas station they're
the most often do you work the gas I
think I will entreat I would say they
see what Kurtzman and Orci it's kind of
hard to say like because they've think
they've written some good films but then
the process of their kind of studio
films a lot of the times scripts like
that will keep going through the latter
and then he got like producers in the
studio heads and everyone's like [ __ ]
changing your script and other people
come on board to make rewrites that you
didn't even know the thing that you
don't know who they work with her
[ __ ] rewriting yeah and then then
ultimately it becomes a director's work
so it's kind of hard for me to criticize
like the writing of their movies even
though there are some that are pretty
bad but and I mean at least Kurtzman or
C specifically do have as many I at
least gotta be as many hits misses and I
think JJ Abrams is a great director who
can kick off [ __ ] yes he's not good in
the middle ground or the conclusion
ground I think I think that's where he
really falls like mi3
as this might be in like not a popular
opinion even though we should I share
this with Ben Bateman and Andrew guy the
action movie industry people mi3 is my
favorite one out of the Mission
Impossible movies and they and they
think that too and and JJ was
specifically approached by Tom Cruise to
helm that film and he really made it his
own
so Tom or JJ changing because no I like
that that movie feels like yeah this is
exactly how JJ especially like JJ Abrams
not so much that like the lost JJ Abrams
more the alias gg like I really feel a
sweat even with the way the movie opens
so I'm like yeah well alias kind of did
the same thing the world you know yeah
to each other why and actually if I'm
not mistaken I'm pretty sure Tom Cruise
saw Elias and that's why he wanted JJ do
it that's cool but either way are you
top or bottom Ken let me know and John
will report back to me would the
information from cost I'll get in
whichever position when I say we got
some people from Australia what's up Tia
how you doing I'm just someone named
checked by odomes so thanks for doing
that we got Scott Welsh here from
Scotland oke Ben Cooper Vancouver I
can't do it Jon do it all from Vancouver
got oh what's your name Scott Scott say
say hi to Tim Horton yeah hi I love we
have a friend Patrick who's from Canada
and one day he showed me a picture of an
actual road work sign that said Tim
Hortons access this way alright so oh
wait we missed Tyler Hague sorry guys we
are taking a little too long creating
some of them so we have like a couple of
windows here open and then we only have
one Oh window here we can like a super
villain if someone does super channelize
this to flash the comment here on screen
but we are behind on that but Tyler
Hague we missed you I'm sorry buddy he
says love you guys
I hated that movie I hate it as chappie
well we appreciate the super chat first
secondly chatty chapters in talking
chappie you're actually in a different
camp here and we're in a different camp
yeah where chappies a really hated movie
it's the opposite where I walked out of
that movie I was like no I think I think
I get it I was like what's going on in
my weird I think I think I get it I was
like there are things you're I
definitely don't like but for the most
part it does a lot more well Tyler
you're not in the minority there no
that's a cold take as a very if we made
the chap movies that people hate like
water movies that you hate it would be
the same [ __ ] like it should we've
heard for years and I guarantee you
chappie would be like we would have
heard chappie
regardless happy likes to paint them um
okay
John okay we read someone's comment here
really second but I guess little kata
who disrespected Jesus himself somebody
wanted to know and I do also want to
know what any cement by Keanu Reeves not
being a good person she was being
sarcastically no but I want to know what
it could have been if she had to answer
for it somebody said cars I don't think
that's a beloved Pixar though I mean
it's a very successful fair I wouldn't
say it's wrong for you to like the good
dinosaur ooh oh we got Lord Martin Laura
Martinez thank you so much I think this
is her first time you tributes is
superjet I've seen your comment coming
in and out of here with about the whole
Chet Lauren says hey guys love your
content
y'all rock my least favorite movie is
Star Trek nemesis
I think this chat has turned into what
are the movies you just don't like it to
me this is highly overrated if you rate
it at all so you don't like Tom Hardy
thank you by the way
but your time you don't like Tom Hardy's
breakthrough role hmm you know what I
don't I don't remember that movie but I
[ __ ] remember that
Taylor oh man oh it's a bad trailer oh
no way was he no he's he's a nemesis or
instruction biggest oh god oh god
starch oh I can't I always know I always
get those two confused this is a piece
actually you're slowly blowing my mind
Tom Hardy's breakout roles in a Star
Trek you didn't know that now no I
didn't I thought it was like winding ref
and I thought it was like Bronson or
something maybe not his first movie but
like that he was the main Vil one of you
guys will definitely clear out of the
chat the main it was one of the main
villains and is either Neman I think I'm
pretty sure it was nemesis and yeah I
think like that
I remember the trailers like alluding to
that he is related to Picard possibly
but his evil no no yes he's also British
no is bald in it they have the same hair
they must be related hey I'm gonna go on
a defense here apparently the good
dinosaur was a movie that's not really
liked apparent for some reason scrap
Zillah 54 in the chat is saying is it
wrong for me to like the good dinosaur
no I don't think it's wrong at all in
fact I that movie had my jaw drop when I
don't know if you guys have seen it I'm
gonna spoil a little bit yeah but in the
the the set up for the movie when the
dinosaur is lost the dinosaurs daddy
dies he's washed away by the river
mm-hmm
and when that happened because I had it
in Cissy I didn't I don't recall any
trailers but I only watched it for the
first time a couple months ago all the
dc+ happen and I was like you just
[ __ ] wipe out the - yeah there's some
real in john city there is like it's
weird
i I don't regard it as one of the like
highest tier Pixar movies but I will say
that some of the backlash I got I did
think was a little overzealous because
yeah like there is some real beautiful
beautiful animation and heavy intensity
to that movie I love the animation it's
strikingly gorgeous and the acid trip is
great well I think the thing that some
of these like animated movies and like
goodness
that can be a little jarring as like the
dinosaur looks very cartoony like it
looks like a cartoon dinosaur but it's
like these he's insanely realistic
backdrops ya know and and buildings and
structures that you're like how did you
how did you build these it's dry right
how does your society and you know other
movies have that problem do you like
cars certainly has that issue we got
someone saying why do you hate Harry
Potter
Oh to someone else hey Thomas sent
Nathaniel Peterson Preston wants to know
why he ate Harry buck so you guys sort
that out and then let us know John we
got ourselves we got ourselves a Philly
gee Thank You Philly G by the way and
John was the reason I watched this movie
so that tells you that someone in this
room right here really loves this movie
luigi attacked the block it is a kid in
that movie said boyega's character moses
never in the stillwell people loved
about that movie i was trying to do a
stallone and then I was like but it's
the lone Philly and then I was like this
is just sound like a New York at Ronnie
Danza let me try to do a middle ground
and then I was gonna go it's up you
beautiful bastard it's a check the block
I mean when they felt the Franco's gonna
change that and it's gonna go over
horribly mmm-hmm what's up horrible
Constance put that on a t-shirt why
don't just spider flu monkey a handle
the fresh but he's the oldest you to
like he's the proto YouTube guy uh I get
why I'm not gonna fight you about it but
is that the point yeah i marks into yeah
the most a one-time but he liked cars
good person yeah I mean that's kind of
the crux of at least the emotional side
of that movie is especially through
Moses but for all the kids it's like
they're living in a project you know in
tough tough situation anyway and then by
the end yeah they come of age a bit you
know but at the same you know if you
didn't like those characters I get it
right right now I gotta ask well Phil eg
thank you
I didn't love it as much as everyone
else but I really appreciated the movie
I'll say that
and I'll say too because I haven't seen
a trailer when I watched that movie I
was actually a little surprised by the
approach it was taking mm-hmm yeah it
gets it goes hard it's ours yeah who
gets intense yeah it doesn't like
necessarily pull you in feeling like
it's gonna especially like you know if
you hear about it but yeah when when it
actually gets down to brass tacks it's
intense there is some actual emotional
weight to like the - that happens on
screen you know because it makes it so
and that movie has a amazing score you
know you can't do a live stream oh sorry
my girlfriend's in the other room I
think I woke her up oh she was taking a
nap I'm sorry
hey we got a squirrel and she just
picked up a giant ass like squirrel cage
yeah [ __ ] massive you I you can climb
in there it's a gross little baby but he
needs the space we have a squirrel weed
We Bought a Zoo underrated Matt Damon
long live thank you Dolan dog I Greg
your performance and It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia was Emmy worthy I was in
as I was in one episode of It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia what is he like 40
only 45 I think I could I'm gonna you
know what if you happen to be here in
this chat I'm gonna tell you why I think
I got that one liner on It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia and he hates
granter yeah I think it's bad old duck
I'm gonna tell you this story I've never
talked about it of why I actually got
because like that's the one line roles
there's like weirdly a [ __ ] ton of
people auditioning for like a one-line
role
I hate gran torino the acting is
terrible what come on redemptive racist
am i right
he's not all bad
all right here's what happened I went
into there to audition and I had that
one line what does he look 40 does that
what you audition with yeah just well I
mean you're reading the one a couple
lines back and forth are waiting for
your timing and [ __ ] and and and and
then she kept messing up her lines and
like the casting director and she just
kept laughing at herself and I couldn't
really say my line because she kept
[ __ ] up and then she just kept
apologizing and that I just got it that
day and I'm so sorry you got that's
beautiful
she felt so bad that I couldn't do my
part so she was just like [ __ ] give
it to him there's one line we're gonna
cast the one guy we didn't see and I
honestly thought this show was gonna be
terrible and it ended up and I did watch
start watching it like I hadn't even
seen that episode until like many years
after it came out because I read the
script and I just thought I was like
this is stupid who's gonna watch this
and then I finally got around to
watching the show like five years after
he came out and I thought it was starik
oh my god I didn't get it until I
watched it yeah and it's a type of show
I think you would have to see on on
screen yeah it was because the weight
like in scripts they have like basic to
things you'd look out for a dialogue and
action lines and the action lines were
read in it like you know how Eli Roth's
personality comes across in interviews
like a total douche Ebro Eli Roth fans
so the the action lines were written as
if like a frat boy wrote you like and
they go to like a mother [ __ ] bad-ass
prom no see [ __ ] like that like a 40
year old kid judging the script Arabs
way unprofessional this is not the way
screenplay should be written and that's
why I got the role thanks for bringing
it up Dylan
I'm sorry I don't like rats right now
somebody in the chat find Greg's moment
and then spliced this audio over essage
commentary souvenir for yourself all
right Tom Holland better than Tobey
Maguire well I will fight you I mean I
don't blame people for saying I don't -
I get it all right guys look we got some
we got some super shots to go through
right here we're gonna read the comments
but any more hours of stream you know I
have I have to finish up an edit and
John it's to finish up an edit for
Doctor Who for patreon so we're gonna
we're gonna be a little bit more
efficient right now because we don't
want to be here all night and I'm pretty
sure we've annoyed the hell out of my
girlfriend who was trying to take a
really calm nap after a stressful day so
expect me to apologize you know maybe
she could send us a super chat for you
know so we got a car girl of joy they
should make a Logan style Sharkboy and
Lavagirl sequel that would I'm for it
and we get Taylor Lautner and and
whoever the girl was back and let
Rodriguez direct it yeah you know what
Carter loved her I'm gonna do you one
better
I'm gonna do you know I got I have an
idea Carter loved her that you just
remind they thank you by the way but I
got one that you're gonna I think you're
gonna love so well I'm just gonna tell
my girlfriend that I'm gonna get some
food for us tonight to make up for be
with us in the hip in the condo we
figure out dinner okay okay John yes
remember these words mm-hmm Space Jam
space space gym who's excited for Space
Jam - ah man alright so here's my
I'm showing my girlfriend the Austin
Powers movies lately I don't know how
this happened literally it's like we're
searching through Netflix forever to
watch something right and then I'm just
like [ __ ] oh this was watched another
awesome she's never seen them so we got
doing Austin Powers - it's a short movie
so here you're good to choose whatever
you want I was fine I'm just going to
bed right after that and then she puts
on Space Jam I haven't seen Space Jam in
years and recently I got a lot of flak
and tellings because there's the
question she said Carla that's from word
at thought and I did Space Jam in years
I got a lot of flack when we did the
video about Space Jam 2 for being like
it's not a really good movie you know
it's like you loved it as a kid but then
when you grow up you're like you realize
like good people are like you real
[ __ ] like sebacean objectively you're
wrong time and place let me see let me
see if this is actually any good and I'm
not gonna lie the first 45 minutes I was
like oh man I shouldn't have said that
this is actually not bad ok but I
couldn't help but think when I was
watching it I just could not help but
think it
it's a weird film because in the
beginning of it it's like a weird
Michael Jordan biopic good to say yeah
it's like a Michael Jordan biopic
spliced in to what you might call it
just a Looney Tunes movie and I was like
well my first thought was well if I were
to restructure this movie I would
probably start with a Looney Tunes thing
first and then go to real life because
the ludus on the Looney Tunes thing
comes in like like 15 minutes into the
film they're like oh yeah look there's
this whole cartoon thing I came here to
watch so that said that so I was like I
wanted to be funny if they did a biopic
and because in the beginning of Space
Jam this is all and because of your
question Carter by the way in the
beginning of Space Jam he's playing
basketball that his dad comes out he's
like they should be gaining some sleep
alright keep shooting until you miss and
and I thought I would love to people you
know doing Space Jam to
which is probably gonna be a soft reboot
I was like I would just remake Space Jam
wouldn't but and and do the Michael
Jordan character again without Michael
Jordan just get someone else to play
Michael Jordan but I would have it be
like a hard heavy drama where it like
the dad is [ __ ] a piece of [ __ ] it's
like we're playing [ __ ] basketball
this is why your mom left
we're trying to [ __ ] sleep on that
one and then you haven't I would do this
like metaphor thing where is it's the
Looney Tunes thing real or is this like
an allegory for escapism yeah then you
feel cut back and forth between the
basketball game and the family of LeBron
James or whoever like going through real
trauma with his disappearance and
everything and he's already you know
kind of absent as the father because
he's on the road all the time you feel
really great Looney Tunes drama because
it hit me halfway through when I'm
watching this movie and Michael George
this glad something hits you halfway
through a side note that the thing that
could have just made Space Jam a better
movie is if someone directed Michael
Jordan a little better because when he
first shows up in Looney tune world he's
just like huh Tweety Bird hmm clothes
money
you're not real and that's his like
whole emotion for the rest no cartoon
because I remember thinking everyone
criticized Michael Jordan is acting in
spaceship until he gets into the loony
toon world you're throwing a not actor
into a situation that we won't have like
efficient technology for for a varial so
I'm like you needed a better guy to
direct and to be like no you got to be
like you're in a hole of their world
that is made of drawings but but my idea
started forming more because I was
thinking Michael Jordan has not brought
up the fact that he has a family yeah
this entire time he's been like I want
to help my friends play basketball he's
got an immediate bond with them and he
drops his family like nothing I saw you
with your kids earlier and the Looney
Tunes break into your house like you
could have sent a note along
could have at least informed serious
wait a minute that's why I was like oh
but if we do a version where his dad was
abusive and that's why he's a neglectful
father to his kids use it the loony toon
world to escape from father this is the
Space Jam remake that we would have done
if we have we ever bring back that
segment how how work it is that that's a
new show we should do bring back kind of
like our fan fiction show except it's
called make it Deep Space Jam but make
it deep here towards ink hey thank you
so much dude I followed you Greg I sent
you a message he's thinking on it looks
like Johnny Depp I'll never forget them
don't make that Iron Man 3 a situation
where I come back to haunt you you mean
like Aldrich Killian are you threatening
to pull an all dirty or are you saying
you're gonna like that at the beginning
of a good healthy working relationship
by the way not a good touchstone a
partnership not a really good
inclination for me to go how is her name
geared toward sync geared towards ink I
thought it was saying geared toward sync
no I thought he was a plumber Wow
now his name is gr ed towe I think are
teasing you know every time my
girlfriend comments in this chat I'm
always paranoid I think you should just
like comment the the regular like hey
later can you go get groceries she
getting this off of you the stream
because I'm like she could she could
probably just hear us through the door
okay somebody hold on I just want to
point out that somebody put up a Mel
Gibson Clayface comment then they'll
give someone make it great okay so it
would be a great Clayface
hot takes let's do it I always say you
redeem yourself by playing a villain
Randi's and random Andy's Channel oh
that's funny hate Eraserhead strange it
guys for people who are doing this chat
we're actually trying to wrap it up off
the trans but random Andy's channel is
saying it which is funny because it's
look your your photo looks like a David
Lynch
I know you guys like your kind of
looking we're doing movies that people
love that that you don't movies that
poke a my mind's not there movies that
people love the Udo really like saying
hate Eraserhead strange and boring well
you probably don't want to watch any
David Lynch just generally speaking well
the thing I love too about this is
that's a list of filmmakers who like if
you don't like one you won't like any
but I'm fascinated by the combination of
strange and boring because I feel like
that is a truly small niche in the
true-true
okay so David Lynch is a very specific
cup of tea by the way mm-hmm so if you
don't like David if you don't like that
movie I wouldn't try to venture out into
other David Lynch I feel like the
hottest David Lynch take you could have
is is hating Twin Peaks or more yeah I
think I'd amazing a howl and drive out
of show made Twin Peaks is probably like
the all-encompassing one but I think out
of out of out of shows yeah out of
movies would be Mahalo try that's the
way you don't want to say you don't like
otherwise you're dumb you know we're
getting a lot of people got a question
from Michael we're but thank you random
Andy's channel what someone's been
asking me how I finished the Spartacus
series hmm
I fell off of it man I fell off of it
like they they had an actor who's
playing Spartacus and everyone and I
think the storytelling in season two is
actually going better than season one
but the guy played Spartacus passed away
unfortunately and so they had to replace
him and it's more than just I'm
distracted by casting I just had so many
issues with the portrayal of the guy who
was playing the new Spartacus that I
couldn't finish it and he's the main
character and I'm like everyone else is
great that the storytelling is better
but to ask you a question whoa
we what what denomination that's India
yeah awesome I've never seen the this
how much you want a badge a beak away
was like go to my brother's livestream
thank you so much dude I hear it's
really tough out that scene yeah I see
news report so what's going on
and yeah it's scared well thank you for
showing your support man extreme luck
Thank You Patrick that's [ __ ] saintly
kind of you thank you seriously what
suck a dick that's a great way to make
anyone feel special I tell you what hi
guys John Rogers super thank you so much
yes hi guys this is my first super chat
being from India hard to catch you live
here's my original joke why did Luke
want to kill Ben he wanted to leave Jedi
and start a restaurant with his dad
Benihana a solo voice the punchline was
good the punchline was worth it to me
I'm pretty sure Karim is Karthik is that
how you say it
I think Karthik is an aspiring stand-up
comedian and then was using this live
stream as a chat to promote himself a
play this is a bringer room he was like
let me test how good my comedy is yeah
if if it works off of not hearing tone
or delivery it should just work out of
the writing real Ali Wong style over
here I mean I don't think it would work
a hundred percent of the time but I
think it's a good one
hey that's a great joke Thank You
Karthik thank you so much now be be safe
please Dan and he had a certain point
just lose the words we might have to do
a you know what John Campea will
sometimes take the super Jets it didn't
do and then do another we might have to
do that because we have so much stuff to
finish tonight that's the goal for the
channel now is to have so many super
checks during the week we just make
videos about those Campea does it
all right so what else do we got in here
real fast okay oh no we're all out I
think no man were you talking about Oh
God Karthik
Josh Wren is asking what's your favorite
daredevil season one two or three easily
won easily won thank you for
contributing by the way but yeah I would
easily say it's number one test at a
daredevil baby come in here you're part
of the chat now whether you like it or
not baby can you bring Rick in here
yeah we need engagement bring a cat and
Jon hold both mice all right with these
daredevil man I guess yeah for me it
would also be Season one although isn't
the Punisher in season two so yes the
thing is like season two is is not as
crisp it not as tight and I haven't seen
season three but uh ah the first one you
know what - the first season and this
might you know um this might be an
unpopular opinion I don't know but I
really enjoyed the balance that
especially the first season had between
Matt being daredevil and being an actual
lawyer so I i weirdly was the guy who
started to miss that this but yeah
what's what what's the right answer to
this question yeah be like the the
mayor's assistant on Powerpuff Girls all
right guys we're about to we're wrapping
this up baby stuff come in here baby
please look look at him look at baby's
legs why are you hiding your face why
are you behind the real rejects logo the
one place where you're obscured all
right guys yes hold on I'll let Rick rub
against it for ASMR dude
this is your the new spider-man right
here recasted Anissa you could just say
the comments you missed my other
superjet so here's my super thank you
all right is this have got me that
matrix sure that the one about the rate
though the reality one yeah yeah you got
that shirt all right all right where is
this chat we missed on all my shirts
have been peed on by Rick by Rick oh I
found it so I found myself my girlfriend
I can't make love unless she has that
mask on even then it's a real 50/50
gamble I mean even I'm starting to sweat
over here real hot and heavy in this
room guys we might get gezi monetize
getting real hot and heavy Nicolas uh I
guess you guys haven't been wrecked yet
he was only in one video but here he is
this is but he's already a celebrity
he's already a celebrity what wasn't
this a super question that she asked and
I did we miss anyone because we need to
finish up a couple of edits and go to
this guys have been so [ __ ] great
thank you so much
yes thank you don't need to put the
Annabelle mask on thank you for riding
the Delirium I'm doing it right now
take the Annabelle mask oh I wish I wish
I could see John in a gas station where
I live oh he pump you full again wait a
minute this is how it hurts just
youtubers I've gotten in trouble
how's it going trying to wrap up this is
the longest live super chat 200 American
I'll show up at any gas station you want
deal how much hotter is in this room
than any other room I play wet like this
is so hot in here
especially during the winter when you go
outside it's like 50 degrees if you're
like but has anyone been in here since
the very beginning and John what would
you do if you saw Nyssa
a gas station I orange mocha frappuccino
commit I can make an awkward joke they
you would do something but you cannot
say you do it or else you could get
canceled just yeah I don't want to get
canned well I mean obviously I would say
I got the rules I know the rules of how
to talk to women there's more to the
check cuz what I would do if I saw her
at the gas stations I was seeing her
happy birthday because she says it is
her birthday month and it's also y'all's
one-year anniversary from the old
apartment since it was my birthday last
year yeah that's right at the end of
April it will be one year since we left
the old place oh that's right look out
that's right oh right you share your
birthday with endgame month yeah
birthday party now hey game month Lauren
Martinez has been here since the
beginning I'm sad oh that's kind of it's
kind of funny to read it like that
I'm sad I've been here since the
beginning how you doing Melanie um
disturb alright it's Disney ruining
Marvel no it's the one thing they're
arguably not really alright guys you
would just start singing happy birthday
for no reason happy birthday alright
guys look we got some videos to film I
mean I wrap up and the editing guys we
got to start the day it's gotten crazy
in here is he peeing
I feel something warm it just feels like
he's always paying you interrupted in
when he was peeing that's why you know
what's funny is like Mike both Olivia
and I thought that cats would hope he
pees on John
both Olivia and that's a hope that's a
prayer right we were hoping we were
worried that the the squirrels the cats
were trying to eat the squirrel but
they're so [ __ ] scared like this
squirrel does not want to do anything
about beyond humans and the cats don't
want anything to do with this I feel
there's something to that idea like like
where elephants get scared of mice like
the idea that it's like a small foreign
creature so it's kind of freaky like the
same way they say that like cats freak
out over cucumbers because they think
they're snakes yeah you know oh yeah
that's true now you got to teach them to
overcome that hunt all right guys
man I see other you know uh I am a
squirrel daddy who does it's 20% of the
word squirrel daddy and the squirrel
girl Olivia will do everything else
Scoob Steve's been peeing good how can
you have a pet a squirrel as a pet is
that legal
yet absolutely is legal is it did you
check yeah there's there's legal way
yeah well yeah BDSM doesn't mean you can
sign a contract do you think this is bad
how about look up the youtubers who have
squirrels as pets and do videos on it
and you'll see new videos of them going
what the [ __ ] yeah I'm broke as [ __ ]
that's my that's my one quote all right
got a nice ascent and we're gonna end
this with the last one from Anisa This
Is It this is a swan song babe how far
do you think I can go with this oh
you're the perfect person is she okay
how far can I go with this comment how
far can I go with this in movie rating
we need we need it in writing what John
would do with a gas nozzle - oh yeah I
remember hearing it wrong it's too far
do you want a hard peach I just I just
feel like what John would do is do what
the blind guy and don't breed was trying
to do but whether with a gas nozzle this
this do
take my hand thank you so much I think
I've answered the question have you guys
played do maternal or Animal Crossing
right that's a double I gotta wash my
hair no we answered yours geared toward
Inc we're gonna we're I'm gonna message
you we did thank you so much gear sir
we're gonna message you as far as it's
fine I can take it this video is gonna
get blocked on YouTube can you make the
the the thing you were gonna say more
explicit well yeah I mean John would
Phillip no Phillip
censorship advertiser friendly you know
what I'm trying to say I'm getting two
people in the room telling me not to say
it well now he would use his special
sauce and fill it up as premium
pump you full of it and some premium
unleaded how's it going are you still
happy to be my girlfriend
and I'll use even more protection
because you gotta wear gloves when you
go to the gas you don't need protection
it's just the nozzle that part only sees
the inside no no car no things that we
won't mention in there I don't know how
to do you did say what okay this is the
last I am I don't want my girlfriend
leaving tonight so I don't want to go
too far but that would make for a really
eventful life I'll send you a map
private message on patreon Oh what job
that way you have it in writing
yeah not ever you can share it across
the internet that way people know I
honored your super check don't know the
context Oh geared towards Inc geared
towards Inc we had missed one right and
this is the last one I meant to say I
followed you and sent you a PM i watch
oh you want to make custom vans for us
oh that would be so cool I just wait did
I go to a vans or Skechers recently
before quarantine vans are better
quality
Wow so dear of course I'm a cheap one me
it's gotta save money and give give 10%
always tithe at the end of the month
Rich Dad Poor Dad taught me that not my
church so yeah yeah what's your
Instagram I'm gonna find you and you
will send us vans what if he's talking
about custom the automobile even better
we're gonna live in a van different
gonna survive this yeah we can think
we'll be able to ship from anywhere this
is looking like a hoarders home at this
point yeah we're we're just hoarding
memorabilia though like from the frame
and the chaos of everything in the
background poop on my hand cats running
through squirrels in [ __ ] all right guys
or a wipe we're gonna end this tune in
next week we will review the Tiger king
each episode individually so she was she
was really pushing that I should watch
it I did what and it was supposed to be
one episode I remembered this night very
well because it was only three nights
ago it was supposed to be one episode
and then it turned into hey look at that
baby look at that always keep writing
says your girlfriend is beautiful you
should be very thankful doesn't that add
that Annabelle mask is that that's a
mask that's not her yeah so you know the
angles like you know on line can't
believe everything you see on a computer
my girlfriend is very beautiful super
sexy we checked we got her tested and
got her tested she does not have Corona
I just meant for beauty it's confirmed I
love her she's amazing she's an
absolutely incredible just say it
same as Monday the same as Monday gonna
find you I got a
a bunch of like requested messages I got
to go through that I'm always like a
year late to them so I'll find you thank
you so much gear tours ink
all right guys everybody thank you thank
you everyone for contributing to this
chat thank you for everyone as Biggers
as the beginning of the chat it's always
the best at the very end
Thank You Rosa Parra we will shout out
all you guys we will write all you guys
in the pin comment of the super chat
John Rosanna Texas - pumping us a full
of semen gasps I love that after all all
that nerve about it's not it's not gonna
just be see there's gonna be mixed in
with actual fuel this is a freak that's
one of those technical words where every
time I hear it I'm always like I'll take
the slang please all right you know how
much we love being here this is the live
streams have been the best part of
YouTube eat every week for the past
three weeks thank you guys so much look
out for more videos get stuck with
Robbie be back here next weekend cuz
we're all quarantined baby show your
face they've seen your face before
yeah you've reacted to things they move
no gas nozzles going on that face I mean
that's how you guys my woman what you
guys do at your gas station is only a
woman's face that's what I got show
backs between you and your gas company I
love all you thank you guys I love you
to stay sane Stacey